lady gaga welcome back to the tonight
show at home edition I love you thank
you so much for honoring you're working
and talking to me today after one
insanely awkward interview with Jimmy
Fallon last week
Lady Gaga returned to the Tonight Show
on Monday with an apology and some big
news
we weren't quite ready and I really
appreciate you being so nice about it
and thank you and I love you I love your
viewers and everyone at home watching I
just wish everybody well we love y'all
too that turned out to be really a kind
of a fun bit for us and I got a lot of
people talking and getting a lot too
excited about what we're about to
discuss tonight oh it got people talking
all right let's rewind last week Gaga
appeared on The Tonight Show Home
Edition but it was a hot mess this is a
big we have a big maybe announcement
that you're gonna say tonight on our
show yeah you're I can't see yeah sorry
apologize yeah like I said a hot
freaking mess
wait what's what's the big news I mean I
don't know what's better the look on
Jimmy's face or the moment she's wearing
her glasses upside down what a wild ride
yeah you wanted some Monday today's
Wednesday so much Monday oh well Gaga
who is self quarantined in her home with
several other people made good on her
word and called back Monday revealing
the news she previously wasn't ready to
talk about I've been speaking at length
with the World Health Organization and
dr. tenders called me and asked me if I
would help curate this special on
television
with global citizen yep gaga announced a
new star-studded TV special called one
world together at home which will be
hosted by Jimmy himself as well as this
fellow late-night host Stephen Colbert
and Jimmy Kimmel I mean come on all
three of you agreed to join forces for a
good cause I'm so happy
and then NBC CBS and ABC every
everybody's working together they'll
have artists we will have lots of
different people will have a fleet we're
also going to have Sesame Street we're
going to have amazing hosts and actors
and the truth is that we're also going
to do a lot of other things that are
going to be different and exciting and
this is what I really want to do with
the show the massive TV event airs April
18th and features performances and
appearances from a ton of artists
including Alanis Morisette Billy Eilish
Billie Joe Armstrong Chris Martin David
Beckham Eddie Vedder Elton John J Balvin
John Legend Kacey Musgraves Keith Urban
Kerry Washington Liz o Stevie Wonder
Paul McCartney Priyanka Chopra and more
that was a mouthful turned out to be
really a kind of fun bit for us but this
TV special isn't the only way the
popstar is giving back Gaga has been
working hard to raise funds for Kovan 19
relief organizations and on Monday she
also appeared on Jimmy Kimmel Live and
explained how she's managed to raise
millions of dollars in just the last
week he did a call with at least just 68
corporate executives and then I've been
doing other calls with philanthropist as
well as major wonderful tech companies
and they've all really stepped up and
they all want to help and it's been it's
been it's been actually wonderful to
watch and I want to help in whatever way
I can
and if all of that wasn't inspiring
enough Gaga also talked about the
importance of showing each other
kindness as we go through this difficult
time
together and I think there's a lot of
people that are at home right now but
I'm wondering how they can help and they
feel like they can't and they don't know
how to and one of the ways that you can
is to be kind this is the catastrophe
and a time of catastrophe kindness is
the most important thing we we must be
compassionate to each other and I think
also self-awareness
while you're being client and making
sure that you know what you have and
what you don't emit you and you you take
those moments to have gratitude
[Applause]
[Music]